what if I told you there was something
that you can do right now that would
have an immediate positive benefit for
your brain including your mood and your
focus and what if I told you that same
thing could actually last a long time
and protect your brain from different
conditions like depression Alzheimer's
disease or dementia would you do it yes
I am talking about the powerful effects
of physical activity that is simply
moving your body has immediate long
lasting and protective benefits for your
brain and that can last for the rest of
your life so what I want to do today is
tell you a story about how I used my
deep understanding of neuroscience as a
professor of neuroscience to essentially
do an experiment on myself in which I
discovered the science underlying why
exercise is the most transformative
thing that you can do for your brain
today now as a
neuroscientist I know that our brains
that is the thing in our head right now
that is the most complex structure known
to humankind but it's one thing to talk
about the brain and it's another to see
it so here is a real preserved human
brain and it's going to illustrate two
key areas that we're going to talk about
today the first is the prefrontal cortex
right behind your forehead critical for
things like decision-making focus
attention and your personality the
second key area is located in the
temporal lobe shown right here you have
two temporal lobes in your brain the
right and the left and deep in the
temporal lobe is a key structure
critical for your ability to form and
retain new long-term memories for facts
and events and that structure is called
the hippocampus so I have always been
fascinated with the hippocampus how
could it be that an event that lasts
just a moment say your first kiss or the
moment your first child was born can
form a memory that has changed your
brain that lasts an entire lifetime
that's what I want to understand I
wanted to start and record the activity
of individual brain cells in the
hippocampus as subjects were forming new
memories and essentially trying decode
how those brief bursts of electrical
activity which is how neurons
communicate with each other how those
brief bursts either allowed us to form a
new memory or did not but a few years
ago I did something very unusual in
science as a full professor of
neuroscience I decided to completely
switch my research program because I
encountered something that was so
amazing with the potential to change so
many lives that I had to study it I
discovered and I experienced the brain
changing effects of exercise and I did
it in a completely inadvertent way I was
actually at the height of all the memory
work that I was doing data was pouring
in I was becoming known in my field for
all of this memory work and it should
have been going great it was
scientifically but when I stuck my head
out of my lab door I noticed something I
had no social life I spent too much time
listening to those brain cells in a dark
room by myself I
didn't move my body at all I had gained
25 pounds and actually took me many
years to realize it was actually
miserable and I shouldn't be miserable
and I went on a river rafting trip by
myself because I had them social life
and I came back thinking oh my god I was
the weakest person on that trip and I
came back with a mission I said I'm
never gonna feel like the weakest person
on a river rafting trip again and that's
what made me go to the gym and I focused
my type-a personality on going to all
the exercise classes at the gym I tried
everything I went to kickbox dance yoga
a step class and at first it was really
hard but what I noticed is that after
every sweat inducing workout that I
tried I had this great mood boost and
this great energy boost and that's what
kept me going back to the gym well I
started feeling stronger I started
feeling better I even lost that 25
pounds and now fast forward a year and a
half into this regular exercise program
and I noticed something that really made
me sit up and take notice I was sitting
in my desk writing a research grant and
a thought went through my mind that had
never gone through my mind before and
that thought was gee grant writing is
going well today and all the stuff yeah
all the scientists always laugh when I
say that because grant writing never
goes well it is so hard you're always
pulling your hair out trying to come up
with that million-dollar winning idea
but I realized that the grant writing
was going well because I was able to
focus and maintain my attention for
longer than I had before and my
long-term memory would I was studying in
my own lab seemed to be better in me and
that's when I put it together maybe all
that exercise that had included and
added to my life was changing my brain
maybe I did an experiment on myself
without even knowing it so as a curious
neuroscientist I went to the literature
to see what I could find about what we
knew about the effects of exercise on
the brain and what I found was an
exciting and a growing literature that
was essentially showing everything that
I noticed in myself better mood better
energy better memory better attention
and the more I learned the more I
realized how powerful exercise was which
eventually led me to the big decision to
completely shift my research focus and
so now after several years of really
focusing on this question I've come to
the following conclusion that exercise
is the most transformative thing that
you can do for your brain today for the
following three reasons number one it
has immediate effects on your brain a
single work out that you do will
immediately increase levels of
neurotransmitters like dopamine
serotonin and noradrenaline that is
going to increase your mood right after
that workout exactly what I was feeling
my lab showed that a single workout can
improve your ability to shift and focus
attention and that focus improvement
will last for at least two hours and
finally studies have shown that a single
workout will improve your reaction times
which basically means that you are going
to be faster at catching that cup of
Starbucks that falls off the counter
which is very very important but these
immediate effects are transient they
help you right after what you have to do
is do what I did that is change your
exercise review regime increase your
cardio respiratory function to get the
long lasting effects and these effects
are long-lasting because exercise
actually changes the brain's anatomy
physiology and function let's start with
my brave favorite brain area the
hippocampus the
hippocampus or exercise actually
produces brand-new brain cells new brain
cells in the hippocampus that actually
increase its volume as well as improve
your long-term memory okay and that that
including in you and me number two the
most common finding in neuroscience
studies looking at the effects of
exercise long-term exercise is improved
attention function dependent on your
prefrontal cortex you not only get
better focus and attention but the
volume of the hippocampus increases as
well and finally you not only get
immediate effects of mood with exercise
but those lasts for a long time so you
get long lasting increases in those good
mood neurotransmitters but really the
most transformative thing that exercise
will do is its protective effects on
your brain here you can think about the
brain like a muscle the more you're
working out the bigger and stronger your
hippocampus and prefrontal cortex gets
why is that important because the
prefrontal cortex and the hippocampus
are there two areas that are most
susceptible to neurodegenerative
diseases and normal cognitive decline in
aging so with increased exercise over
your lifetime you're not going to cure
dementia or Alzheimer's disease but what
you're going to do is you're going to
create the strongest biggest hippocampus
and prefrontal cortex so it takes longer
for these diseases to actually have an
effect you can think of exercise
therefore as a supercharged 401k for
your brain okay and it's even better
because it's free
so this is a point in the talk where
everybody says that sounds so
interesting Wendy but I really will only
want to know one thing and that is just
tell me the minimum amount of exercise I
need to get all these changes and so so
I'm gonna tell you the answer to that
question first good news you don't have
to become a triathlete to get these
effects the rule of thumb is you want to
get three to four times a week exercise
minimum 30 minutes an exercise session
and you want to get aerobic exercise in
that is get your heart rate up and the
good news is you don't have to go to the
gym to get a very expensive gym
membership add an extra walk around the
block in your power walk you see stairs
take stairs and power vacuuming can be
as good as the aerobics class that you
were going to take at the gym so I have
gone from memory pioneer to exercise
Explorer from going into the innermost
workings of the brain to try to
understand how exercise can improve our
brain function and my goal in my lab
right now is to go beyond that rule of
thumb that I just gave you three to four
times a week 30 minutes I want to
understand the optimum exercise
prescription for you at your age at your
fitness level for your genetic
background to maximize the effects of
exercise today and also to improve your
brain and protect your brain the best
for the rest of your life
but it's one thing to talk about
exercise and it's another to do it so
I'm going to invoke my power as a
certified exercise instructor to ask you
all the stand up
we're gonna do just one minute of
exercise it's call a response just do
what I do say when I say and make sure
you don't punch your neighbor okay music
five six seven eight it's right left
right left and I say I am strong now
let's hear you
[Applause]
ladies I am Wonder Woman's strong let's
hear you
new move uppercuts right and left I am
inspired now you say it
let's move pull it down right and left
right and left I say I am on fire now
you say it
and done okay good job
thank you I want to leave you with one
last thought and that is bringing
exercise in your life will not only give
you a happier more productive life today
but it will protect your brain from
incurable diseases and in this way it
will change the trajectory of your life
for the better thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]